bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france que va cibler
concrètement est précisément cette
nouvelle réglementation alors ce qui est
lisse et que ce sont toutes les
transmissions en direct qui a un site
sollicito contribuer à des infractions
terroristes qui fournit des instructions
pour de telles infractions
donc c'est vraiment je dirais que les
bons sentiments au plus tôt les bonnes
attentions sont affichés je pense que
tout le monde peut en être satisfait car
on sait que la préparation souvent de
ces actions théorie se fait en numérique
pendant la question qu'il faut se poser
c'est il faut toujours se demander s'il
ya pas un risque de dérapage s'il n'y a
pas un risque pour commun des mortels
sont communs du citoyen de voir des
contenus disparaître comme ça une heure
c'est rapide
donc voilà c'est la question que pose
plusieurs dizaines d'organisations
défense droit de l'heure et je crois
qu'ils ont raison de le poser mon con on
pèse le pour et le groupe maintenant la
décision étant prise on va voir comment
il va être appliquée parce que pour
qu'on comprenne bien au sein de chaque
état membre de lieux qui sera habilité à
émettre à l'injonction de retirer du
contenu dans l'eure lorsque dit là se
disent cette proposition ou ce règlement
du parlement européen une part d'une
autorité de contrôle
donc c'est difficile de dire à des taux
d'aujourd'hui quelle sera cette autorité
de ce sera probablement une autorité
administrative si on passe en dehors
service public de la justice du
judiciaire
je pense les choses vont se passer ainsi
car c'est clair que pour pouvoir réagir
comme ça en quelques heures quelques
minutes c'est pas de salle explique de
la justice ait pas eu ici capable de le
faire faut faire apparaître autorités
administratives
c'est à la fois je dirais lui course
contre la montre qui peut effectivement
encore une fois qui est fondée sur de
bonnes intentions
avec toujours évidemment le risque on
aille trop vite
et une fois qu'on a retirés des contenus
écoutez ses complices sont l'objet alors
vous l'avez rappelé la législation
suscite les inquiétudes des défenseurs
des libertés publiques une soixantaine
d'organisations de défense des droits
humains d'associations de journalistes
et chercheurs s'inquiètent du pouvoir
qui pourraient être données au ministère
de l'intérieur
qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait envisager pour
éviter un risque de censure selon vous
déjà ce qu'il faudrait envisager je
pense qu'on sera dans ce système là
c'est des recours possibles
évidemment leur retrait en une heure
c'est enfin une heure de recours ne
prendra pas eu l'heur mais c'est qu'on
doit reste évidemment dans l'état de
droit mais ça je pense que des choses
dans l'union européenne sont quand même
assez bien établie on est en état de
droit donc qu'il faudra que les recours
soient effectivement confirmé lorsqu'on
mettre en application sa c'est la
première chose
la seconde de s'en douter c'est qu'on
dégage quand même des critères au fur et
à mesure où les choses avancent des
critères qui sont objectifs haddad
aujourd'hui ce que l'on va considérer
comme étant une infraction théorie ce
sont des intentions des annonces ont
peut-être qu'on pourra préciser des
choses
voilà je dirais que c'est c'est c'est
dans l'air du temps
la surveillance numérique parce qu'il ya
c'est aussi ça il faut bien voir que si
on met en place des autorités qui
peuvent réagir dans l'eure ça veut dire
qu'on avait beaucoup de surveillance et
donc la surveillance électronique
elle est née à la cure 11 septembre 2001
est donc cet énorme attentats à new york
et effectivement on est encore dans
cette lignée là
vingt ans après voilà on n'a pas tourné
la page
il ya des événements qui malheureusement
nous démontre qu'on a raison d'être
toujours vigilant mais il faut aussi que
les citoyens soient eux-mêmes vigilant
on ne retire pas trop de leur liberté et
à l'art au delà de cette question
légitime de la censure du risque de
censure est ce qu'il aura un réel impact
selon vous ce texte de quels nouveaux
outils va se doter l'europe pour lutter
contre la propagande terroriste sur le
net
alors ici pas tout à fait puisque c'est
l'incitation à commettre des infractions
déjà on va dire dans le commencement
d'exécution et vous avez raison de poser
des questions parce que quelle est la
différence entre la propagande et le
commencement d'exécution de ce très
compliqué voilà par exemple une autre
question à laquelle il faudra peut-être
avoir des réponses et des précisions
l'europe d'abord quelque part on
s'affranchit des systèmes juge
judiciaire
c'est ce qu'on disait à l'instant est ce
que c'est une autorité administrative
qui va donner une instruction à une
société du secteur privé qui va
effectivement censurée
comme vous l'avez dit un contenu parce
que on a considéré ça ça voulait dire
qu'on allait inciter à commettre une
infraction
donc effectivement on est sur d'autres
d'autres peut-être valeur d'autres eu
d'autres considérations et donc je crois
que l'europe a raison de ceux de
réfléchir à des mécanismes qui
permettent de lutter contre ce type
d'infraction car on a eu l'exemple
récent à rambouillet elle est
pratiquement à chaque loup solitaire
on se rend compte qu'il a des contacts
qu'il a des vidéos qui sont visionnées
donc l'espace numérique est propice à
motiver tous et nous solitaire qui sont
plus souvent des esprits faibles et des
gens perdus et dans la société
médiatique de ce dernier terroristes
donc oui on a raison d'essayer d'aller
un peu à la racine ou à la cause de leur
déclenchement de leur action voilà je
crois que c'est une course mais de
l'europe qui est difficile et et qui est
un peu entre le marteau et l'enclume
entre nous de liberté et cette lutte
légitime contre le terrorisme et est ce
que les plateformes jour enjeux quelles
sanctions sont prévues ses mains alors
j'imagine qu'il y aura des sanctions qui
seront adoptées en contrepartie d'un
refus d'obtempérer
m
retard ça c'est un mécanisme qu'on
connaît en europe depuis 2002 puis une
directive en 2000 qui à l'époque demandé
aux plateformes de retirer les contenus
illicites ne sais pas c'était pas focus
n'étaient pas concentrés ce terroriste
est contenu illicite au sens large et à
l'époque on parlait pas mal de propriété
intellectuelle rappelez-vous dans les
années 2000 bon ce qu'on peut constater
c'est que depuis vingt ans que cette
réglementation est en vigueur en europe
et qui a été transposée en france en
2004 depuis 16 ans en règle générale ça
a plutôt bien fonctionné en tout cas sur
des contenus droits d'auteur sur les
paroles de m
et là par contre je pense qu'il ya un
échec flagrant qui est dû au fait que
ces massifs il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
contenu et probablement que les des
plateformes comme facebook youtube ou
google et twitter ne joue pas toujours
de jeu merci beaucoup pour votre regard
olivier iteanu je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat spécialiste en droit numérique